NICK BUTCHER: Hello
and welcome to
Android Design in Action.
This week, we've got a
jam-packed show where we're
going to take you through some
of the redesigns of the Google
Play applications.
We're very lucky to be joined
by some special guests from
the Android design
team this week.
So as always, I am your
host, Nick Butcher.
And in New York, we have--
ROMAN NURIK: Hey guys,
Roman Nurik here.
And over in Mountain View
we have our special
guests Marco and Owen.
Do you want to introduce
yourselves a little bit, guys?
MARCO PAGLIA: Hi everybody.
Thank you for having us here.
My name is Marco
and I lead user
experience for Google Play.
OWEN OTTO: Hi.
I'm Owen Otto.
I'm the lead designer on the
Google Play music app.
NICK BUTCHER: Great.
So thanks very much
for joining us.
So without any further ado,
let's jump into some of the
processes behind
the redesigns.
MARCO PAGLIA: Great.
So let's get started.
So Google Play you're probably
familiar with it, but this is
a quick introduction.
Google Play is the media
offering from Google.
It basically covers all your
content from games to apps,
music, books, movies,
and magazines.
It's the place where you
get your content.
It's the place where
you enjoy it.
So today we're going to be
talking about the redesign.
Particularly, there are three
key words that are going to go
across the presentation, is how
we design it responsive,
how we made it responsive,
modular, and
emotional at the same time.
So we had three goals in mind
when we redesigned the Google
Play suite of applications.
One was to create consistency
across Play, to populate
content dynamically, and to
create efficient layout on web
and device.
So creating consistency.
Basically, if you have been
using Google Play in the past,
you would have seen that we had
a lot of different ways to
represent content.
And we thought that we sort of
needed to make it uniform in
order to create an experience
that felt familiar to people.
Populate content dynamically
means that while we had ways
to display content in a dynamic
way across devices and
web, there were certain types
of content, particularly
collections, that couldn't
be displayed dynamically.
For example, you will remember
those tiles that were
promoting different collections
of content.
Those tiles had to be
manually drawn,
generated, exported in JPEGs.
And so we couldn't either
propose content based on your
preferences, collection based on
your preferences because we
had to produce those
tiles beforehand.
And also it was a very labor
intensive process.
When we talk about efficient
layout, it's not about the
layout being efficient,
but it's rather make
our work more efficient.
So we had to design for a lot
of different screens and
platforms, including the web.
And we just wanted to have a
system so that designers could
define and design their layouts
once and apply them to
all platforms.
So we could focus more on the
new features and the cool
stuff rather than translating
the same thing
over and over again.
So let's jump into the solution
and the design
principles that took us
through this journey.
So everything starts
with cards.
The interesting thing about
cards is that it is this
[INAUDIBLE] element that
defines an entity, that
defines an object.
And so rather than designing
grids, which is a sort of
outside in approach where you
have grids and you put stuff
in it, we thought about cards
being this [INAUDIBLE] element
that creates spaces from
the inside out.
So multiple cards shows up on
your layout and define the
content that you see.
Let me get into some examples.
So a card is great because,
like I said, it contains
objects, whether they are
applications or albums or
movies or magazines or books
or even people or
artists and so forth.
They basically can contain any
type of thing and by being in
the same module, we are able to
display things next to each
other, no matter what kind
of entity they are.
The other great property that
cards have is the ability to
be in different shapes.
So we design a lot of different
cards so that the
[INAUDIBLE] could be more
interesting and hierarchical.
So we had what we call tiny
cards or small cards or big
cards, and cards can also
be displayed in multiple
orientations in order to
accommodate different layouts.
We also have what we call a
medium card or a list view
type of card.
So there are two things that
having different sizes
accommodate for.
One is that they create
hierarchy.
They can show things to be more
important by being bigger.
And also to accommodate for
different informational
purposes, meaning they can have
more or less white space
in them to show more or
less information.
For example, in the store, when
we find something that
you maybe like, we put in a
bigger card which has a bigger
info area in order for display
more reasons about why you may
like it, or maybe we can
display people that
+1 it and so forth.
And same we do on other
applications and you'll see
that in music later.
Another key element of our
design are canvasses.
So once you understand cards,
you also understand how your
application is basically just
a canvas on top of which
elements are displayed.
So it doesn't matter if the
canvas is the store or music
or whatnot.
The point is that you have
content that is displayed on
top of these canvases.
Somehow our design tries to be
APK agnostic in a way that you
may see in the future a book
in the music application.
Why not?
The store is a perfect example
where all the content come
together in one place.
Another great example of
canvases is what we do today
in the movies application.
If you're familiar with it, when
you pause a movie, you
basically see the actor
that is there.
You see similar movies where
the actor has been
participating in.
And this is just a canvas.
It is a canvas where we display
on top of it a person
card and a list view card with
a bunch of movies in it.
It just about canvases the
content lives on top of them.
Another notion that is
key to our design is
the notion of clusters.
So once you have multiple cards
next to each other,
because of the visual psychology
law of proximity,
you perceive it as one
unit, a cluster.
And that allows us to display
collections in this way.
We also made these collections
to be dynamic and follow that
hierarchy that I talked about
before by allowing a cluster
to have different
models in them.
And because we designed those
cards beforehand to be plugged
in to each other through
heights, they are following
the same structure.
We can basically display
clusters that have different
types of cards in them
and still feel as a
unit, as you see here.
Also naturally, the clusters
they work across our typical
canvases like phones, or
tablets, and web and beyond.
This led us into this responsive
layout philosophy.
When we talk about responsive
layout, we're talking more
about a design approach,
rather than the
responsive web designer.
So we're not talking about
designing your website to
respond to different canvases,
but rather how as designers we
thought about how our layouts
will expand across multiple
screen sizes.
And this is what we define here
as responsible layout and
responsive design.
So as you see, we took into
consideration all the typical
canvases from phones to tablet,
seven inch, to tablet
10 inches, and typical
laptops.
We always had all those canvases
in mind and we kept
on designing throughout
these canvases
across the whole process.
We didn't start from phone or
from a particular tablet.
The process took us through all
these canvases, and all we
were thinking about was how
many columns these layouts
will be supported on.
It's just a number of columns.
We ended up almost not calling
phones phones anymore, but
just calling them four inches
or three inches or maybe two
columns layout, three columns
layout, et cetera.
Let's get into the output a
little bit and then we will
jump into music which is a great
example of how these
principles are applied
in practice.
But some examples that I want to
show in these layouts are,
for instance, this is the store
and you can see how the
same types of cluster scales
across all screens.
In particular, this particular
movie is recommended to me
bigger because a friend
of +1 it.
And you see how its prominence
hierarchy is scaled across
phone, a seven inch, and a ten
inch tablet, growing in size,
and allowing other content to
display next to it by keeping
that hierarchical
relationship.
On phone you don't see other
content part of the same
cluster just because the space
doesn't allow that, but when
you get to the 10 inch tablet
instead, we have a very
beautiful big cover with other
related content next to it
which is recommended to me.
When we're talking about
modularity, we also applied
the same principles in the store
in the way we show our
banners, in the way we apply
our photography to our
collections.
For example, here you see that
we have an author photos next
to the content and you see how
we show more or less content
according to the number of
columns supported by the
particular device.
And you also see how the photo
shifts a little bit.
So on phone, it shifts a little
bit to the left in
order to always be centered
in that particular place.
But this responsive layout,
this efficiency, is also
applied to the way we started
producing these assets, these
photography.
It is always a 16 by 9 photo
that scales and moves a little
bit across all devices.
And the same is true even
for our banners.
Finally, about familiarity.
Like I said before, we
want to be as much as
possible APK agnostic.
Our experience has to feel
just like one experience.
And so by making all layouts
look and feel the same, you
have this transitional point,
for example, that feels really
natural and smooth.
For example, in the books
application, we have a set of
recommendations at the bottom.
And when you expand those
recommendations you're lending
to the store, but in reality,
the view is exactly the same.
So the user will just feel
like he's expanding his
collection.
He wants to see all the elements
present in the
collection.
And he won't necessarily think
about now I just landed into a
different APK.
So this allows us even to mix
our applications more and I
guess creating some cross
vertical opportunities across
our play applications.
And finally about familiarity,
by applying the same design
principles across all the play
applications for it, you
basically see how we start
generating a type of brand
that happens to be visible
across all of them.
It's just very recognizable.
It's very playful through the
varied colored action bars
through this cards type of
metaphor through this grid.
It really starts feeling like
something that differentiate
from other applications present
out there and it feels
very Googely.
Now we're going to
talk about music.
So I'll let Owen to continue.
OWEN OTTO: Hi.
Now I'm going to give you a
little walk through on how we
applied some of the principles
Marco was just talking about
to the design of the music
app, in specific.
And I wanted to start with just
perhaps a provocative
idea within the design
community.
There's this notion that we
should be designing for mobile
first that's very
popular lately.
Previously, maybe people were
designing web apps and then
they were kind of figuring out
how to scale them down to the
phone, which we realized was a
bad idea, and maybe we should
focus on the phone first.
And I think where we've moved
onto as is possibly a next
step in this evolution,
which is designing for
everything at once.
So as Marco mentioned, we were
thinking about not just the
phone, but the seven inch tablet
and the 10 inch tablet
and the web.
And even in music's
case, the TV.
So practically speaking, one
trick that we used to approach
this problem is we found that
if we, on a first pass, we
kind of think about the phone
in portrait and the 10 inch
tablet in landscape, that this
sort of stretches the design
and really makes us think
through things
in a way that scales.
So I'm going to give you a
little demo of the music app
with a phone in portrait and
the tablet in landscape.
And I'll talk about these
principles that Marco was
mentioning as well as just
showing you some cool things
in the music app.
So this is our Listen
Now page.
It's sort of the home
screen in the app.
The basic idea of this is when
you have a music subscription
service and you suddenly have
millions of tracks at your
fingertips, it can be
a little daunting to
figure out what to play.
So this screen tries to
be your concierge.
It knows your taste and tries
to pick what you may want to
play next to make this easy.
And this really shows the grid
system that Marco was talking
about and how it scales and
solves the problem on both the
phone and the tablet.
So what you see here is we have
a two column grid on the
phone and the five column grid
on the tablet, as well as
different card sizes.
There's a sort of small or
medium sized card on the phone
with a Daft Punk at the top and
this very large card on
the tablet.
And it just brings a familiar
experience to the user between
both form factors, as well as
making it easier for us to
design and easier for engineers
to implement when we
reuse these grids and
card systems.
Next I wanted to show you what
an artist page looks like.
So this is the page
for She and Him.
They have a new album out now.
And the thing that we thought
was really interesting in this
layout here is in opposition
to a kind of
typical tablet layout.
Like imagine in a Gmail app
where you have sort of one
column that has all of the
messages and on the right is
sort of an expansion of
one of those messages.
We decided to go over here on
the tablet where we really
stick with just one panel, but
we make the graphics really
large and beautiful
and immersive.
As well as by using the cluster
layout, the same one
that I was talking about before
in the Listen Now
screen, you can scale up to
fill the page nicely.
You can also see in action on
this page the cluster model
that we were talking about
before that's spread out
throughout all the Play apps
where you can have different
sections, in this case related
artists, and you can expand
them to get to more.
Next I want to show you
our playlist screen.
One of the really cool things
we have in the service is we
actually have a team of editors
who are sitting around
making these awesome playlists,
things like--
I like this one called Intro
to Nordic Metal.
So you can learn about new
genres you don't know anything
about or keep up to date on a
genre that you're really into.
This is one I've been listening
to lately that's on
Indy Electronic.
One of the really nice things
that we came up with on this
page was we wanted to continue
that design that I was showing
on the artist page where we have
a big immersive graphic
at the top.
But when we got to the playlist
page, we were like,
what do we do because the
artist, there's a lot of
artists on this page?
And we struck upon the idea
of just doing this kind of
rotating carousel.
So you can see on many different
artists photos from
all the songs that are
in the playlist.
Another interesting thing here
about the relationship between
the phone and the tablet in
landscape is you can see over
here on the song list on the
tablet, we've got a little bit
more room here.
So rather than showing the song
title and the artist name
right next to each other as we
do on the phone, we spread
them out into separate columns
on the tablet.
And you can also bring in a
little bit more information on
the tablet like the song
duration, which just doesn't
really fit nicely
on the phone.
Another example of this same
kind of principle is in our
Now Playing bar which you see
at the bottom of both the
phone and the tablet, which
shows you the currently
playing song and gives
you a few controls.
Now on the phone where there's
not a lot of space, we just
have a play button in addition
to the song info.
But on the tablet, we give you
a full previous button and
next button and even thumbs up
and thumbs down so you can do
some rating.
So it's just that you can take
the same elements and just add
a little bit more
on the tablet.
But you still maintain that
consistency and reusing the
same components from an
engineering perspective.
ROMAN NURIK: One of things I
wanted to call out really
quickly is that this isn't
like two separate apps.
Throughout this entire
presentation or demo so far
you guys have basically been
showing the same app on a
phone and a tablet.
It's just that the individual
elements in the app, the
individual elements within the
Now Playing bar and within the
kind of song list, those stretch
and those kind of
realign themselves or
position themselves.
That's one of my favorite things
about this app is that
it's truly a responsive
design at the
individual component level.
OWEN OTTO: Yeah.
That's really important
to our approach.
A couple other things
I wanted to mention.
One cool thing we did on the
phone because we didn't have
room for those next and previous
buttons, we have
these little touches like you
can swipe to go the next song.
It's pretty cool.
And the next piece I want
to talk about is
our Now Playing screen.
This, again, shows the idea we
were talking about before
where the same design when you
have these large graphics,
scales to both form factors.
Maybe the graphic gets cropped
a little bit differently, but
it still is beautiful
and immersive.
And again, you can swipe to go
to the next track on the Now
Playing screen.
It's pretty nice.
The last piece I wanted to talk
about is our Queue UI.
This is where you can see what
songs are coming up next.
And here there's some
other nice gestures.
You can swipe to remove songs if
you don't want to hear one.
Now on the tablet, we did a
nice little touch to just
customize for the tablet and use
this space well, which is
just that rather than making
this be a full screen like it
is on the phone, the queue, we
made it just be a pop up.
So you can still stay in your
Now Playing screen without
kind of having to leave
to go somewhere else.
So that's the basic idea is to
design for the phone and
tablet and think about
all the other
screens at the same time.
And a lot of these components
can be reused and scale with
just slight tweaks to optimize
for the form factor.
NICK BUTCHER: All right.
Excellent.
Thank you very much for
going through that.
That's a brilliant whirlwind
tour of cards philosophy
behind Google Play and
how to apply it.
I had a few questions I
wanted to pick up on.
So you said you're trying to
think about all devices at
once when you're designing.
Practically, how do you
go about doing that?
I mean, do you have a large
canvas with all the different
screen sizes all at once?
How do you actually go
about doing this?
OWEN OTTO: You want
me to take that?
MARCO PAGLIA: Sure.
OWEN OTTO: So I think one tact
is the one I was mentioning
which is when we're going in
deep on a design, we may think
we may narrow the scope down
at first to the phone in
portrait and a tablet
in landscape.
But I think another key piece is
that we worked on the Store
app everywhere in great
detail at first.
So this allowed us to then learn
a lot about the patterns
and how they work on the
different form factors, and we
could bring that back
to each of the
different vertical apps.
MARCO PAGLIA: Yeah.
There's a lot to say about a
good technique for having a
suite of applications
to be consistent.
To basically reinvest on one
first in order to get to learn
all the lessons that needs to be
learned and to do the best
tweaks on the layouts.
And then sort of expand that
to other applications.
There's a lot of code that
can be re-utilized.
And that becomes very useful.
We're actually moving into a
space where we try to make
those components more a
part of the framework.
And that will be the ultimate
goal, to really have these
components to be called by any
Play application and just
inherit a lot of properties.
From the design side, I wish you
could come to our office,
because it's pretty
interesting to
see the way we work.
Most the time you see people,
for example, working on
Illustrator and multiple
canvases representing phones
and tablets next to each other
and just copy and pasting
elements from one another,
see if they work.
I think it's very important from
a design perspective to
have tools that allows you to
see things at the same time to
support canvases.
And I think a lot of
applications that we use today
have made great progress
allowing for that.
NICK BUTCHER: Cool.
ROMAN NURIK: One of the
questions I had was in terms
of how you communicate
with engineers.
So this is actually something
that we've covered before.
We've covered this when Alex
Faaborg from your team joined
us, but just wanted
to get your take.
So during the process of
designing the Google Play
client apps as well as the
Google Play music app, can you
share any tips and tricks or
anything like that from the
process of working with
the engineering team?
MARCO PAGLIA: So one important
thing for us
is to be very specific.
So skipping all the details
about how we get to design
those applications in the
first place and all the
creativity that goes into it,
but focusing on the specs, if
you wish, which is where
we have a very tight
collaboration with
engineering, we make red lines.
We make a lot of very detailed
specifications because it's
very important to
produce mocks.
And it's very important to
define all paddings, all phone
sizes, everything that is
necessary to make this layout
to be the way we
want it to be.
But like I said before, if you
have these modular places in
mind, it's really important to
get to a very precise level,
the finish in the first time,
but after that, it's done.
There's a lot of code that
can be shared afterwards.
So what happened is that we
had to produce a lot of
guidelines and specifications,
especially for the Store which
shaped first.
But after that, we managed to
have engineering to be talking
to each other and get a lot of
that information almost for
free which which was
very important.
NICK BUTCHER: Is that another
example of your inside out
rather than an outside
in approach?
So by going deep and working on
the Play Store and defining
detailed red lines for different
sizes of elements,
you were then just able
to say use the same--
MARCO PAGLIA: Yes.
NICK BUTCHER: --as well?
Yes.
Exactly.
And about the communication,
documents are never enough and
they keep on changing.
So we also have a specific
website which is where we post
all our materials and they
are more accessible.
And this is where engineering
can go and get all the
information that they need.
Plus, we are lucky, we work next
to the engineering team.
We are part of the same team.
We're in the same building.
And so nothing can be better
than face to face of course.
It's obviously very hard to
get to the right level of
specification by simply writing
documents, especially
when you get to motion design
and all those nuances that
Owen has shown like the playlist
design if you don't
sit next to each other.
OWEN OTTO: I think one other
thing I'd add that applies
that we really did in the Google
Play redesign and just
applies to working with
engineers in general is to get
the engineers involved really
early in the process.
So I started meeting with
engineers and presenting when
we just had really rough
sketches of the information
architecture and kind of a rough
idea of how different
features would work, not
beautiful mocks, not things
were red lined out or anything,
but just kind of the
rough strokes.
And through that, we get
everyone's feedback early on
and also learn about things that
might be technical issues
that we might want to work
around in the design or tweak
to make sure that we have a
really good user experience at
the end of the day.
ROMAN NURIK: Thanks.
NICK BUTCHER: I want to ask
a quick question about the
awesome use of the Action
Bar and the translucent
background.
So hopefully people noticed
it in the demo there.
But one of my favorite features
of the app is on the
menu screen, like the artist
screen for example.
You start off with a fully
translucent action bar.
And then as you scroll down the
content, it fades in the
background [INAUDIBLE].
To me, it works brilliant for
making the most of the imagery
as well as working with
the Action Bar
pattern very, very flexibly.
Can you give us some background
on how you came up
with that or what were your
design goals for that piece?
OWEN OTTO: I think basically the
idea was we really wanted
to focus on the imagery, and by
a sort of making the Action
bar be transparent, it really
made the image pop more and
more of the centerpiece
of the screen.
And then I don't remember who
came up with the idea of it
kind of fading into orange, but
roughly, it was to solve
the problem of that when you
scrolled down, you needed to
make sure that you could see the
controls when the picture
wasn't there anymore.
And so it just wound up being
kind of a cool touch to solve
that problem.
MARCO PAGLIA: Yeah and something
to say about the
Action bar.
I think there's a lot of ways
that we can play with Action
bars to be differentiating
within applications.
And this is a very
good example.
And you have a lot of examples
on Android in general.
So in Play, for instance, we
decided to put a flat icon
instead of the 3D icon
in the Action bar.
We made this Action
bar very flashy.
We kind of invested in them and
we invested in the colors
that we have.
At the same time, when you get
to an artist, you kind of feel
that that is the
artist's page.
It's not the music page.
And so it has to belong
to the artist.
And that's why it has
to feel that it's
more neutral as possible.
And like I said before, a lot
of examples on Android today
about different uses of Action
bar that can make our layout
very flexible.
Another example that I can
remember, for example, is the
agenda view on a calendar on a
phone where the Action bar
shows one of the items of the
agenda view itself and so it
shows the information
present in there.
It doesn't have any
calendar icon.
And it's just part of
the informational
structure of the page.
Same goes with the people
application where in a
[INAUDIBLE]
of the people application, the
Action bar takes the name of
the person and it's not just the
anti-real estate to have
an app for them.
So I re-invite everybody to
think about ways that we can
play with the Action bar but
still keeping it consistent
because that really
affects usability.
So it's important to obviously
stick to the patterns.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah definitely.
I think it's one of the best
ways you can bring branding to
your application as well.
You have this bar that
[INAUDIBLE].
I think you've done a really
nice job in the Play app so
that it's obviously a suite
of very closely--
like close cousins apps.
You can tell that they're
designed together in concert,
but they have their own
personality right through the
different colors and so forth.
So I think that's a really nice
use of the Action bar to
bring that branding to
each individual app.
MARCO PAGLIA: There's some other
tricks that we made with
color that you can
pay attention to.
For example, we have, instead
of affordances like the
pinning icon and other icons
that change color according to
the application you're in.
So on music, everything is
styled to be orange.
In books, everything is
styled to be blue.
In magazines, everything
is styled to be purple.
And same goes even with
the touch feedback.
If you pay attention to the
music app, the touch feedback
is actually an orange overlay,
while on the books application
it's a blue overlay.
There are a lot of little
touches that we put here and
there to make each application
to feel very playful but also
part of the same family.
ROMAN NURIK: One quick thing I
wanted to point out for the
developers that are in the
audience, if you're looking to
do some sort of kind of accent
color styling of your app and
if you create some specs or
mocks from a designer that
says everything should be of a
certain accent color or brand
color, you can use a tool called
Android Holo Colors and
also the Action bar style
generator to do that for you.
NICK BUTCHER: Right.
So I think we might have run
over a little bit but that was
some wonderful content you guys
have presented to us.
So thank you very much for
being our guest today and
coming and presenting that.
So that's all for this week.
Thanks very much for joining
us once again on Android
Design in Action.
And we'll see you soon.
MARCO PAGLIA: Thank
you for having us.
OWEN OTTO: Thanks.
MARCO PAGLIA: Bye.
Bye everybody.